how you guys doing sorry good uh so I
really want to start with that trailer
is fantastic thank you and it really uh
looks darker and different than the
first season so what can you say about
that I think when setting out to make it
aesthetically we wanted to really take
our audience and put them into the place
of the soldier in the fight so that
means like introducing that element of
the The Fog of War um and uh so that our
audience isn't seeing things that our
characters don't see not knowing things
that our characters don't know and it
let us kind of create um this great kind
of eeriness and tension where you know
you're never sure how big the enemy
force is like just out of our our sight
and we you know I think did we're really
consistent with it um and I think it's
come out really beautifully so I'm
pretty pleased and that was that was
part of bringing David on right bringing
David on for season 2 was to really get
to a more grounded place with how the
show so looked and feel felt in the
story and the stakes are higher in
season 2 right and that's something you
need to be able to really feel um not
just be told um and that's something we
knew David would be able to execute on
beautifully uh so season 1 ends how much
time be is a jump be from season one to
season two you've said six months six
months yeah um there's enough time for
change uh and also some time for some of
the outcomes of season one to
crystallize and and settle in you know
so it's Eight Episodes I Believe season
two uh which is the episode or episodes
that you cannot wait for fans to see you
don't have to spoil anything I'm just
wondering the numbers one two three
four yeah five five is probably my
favorite do you want do you want to
tease why or just say five no okay
that's fine I accept that it's different
I like it when there's different answers
four and you're like five yeah and there
I mean that's the thing right like
there's the high action which is
actually spread pretty well throughout
the season and then there's some of
these personal stories and so I think
for different people depending on you
know what they love the most they're
going to have a different favorite
episode so you'll understand when you
see five maybe why it's my favorite one
of the things now that you're in season
2 when you're making the first season
you really don't know am I going to get
a second season but you get the second
season you know wait the studio is
serious about this they're investing
more resources so how much when you guys
were figuring out season 2 are you
looking at a bigger long-term plan in
terms of well like setting up season 3
or season 4 if you're lucky enough to
get there I all I mean I think if you're
true to the story you want to leave
yourself with doors to walk through at
the end um we have a lot it's such a
huge world there's so much of uh the the
legacy of of you know the the lore but
also um every kind of solution brings
about its own problems at the end of the
season and um I think that it's a great
springboard I hope we get the chance to
make more that that's totally intention
you do think about it I would be lying
if I said we didn't um you always have
to assume the best right and you want to
be writing with that long-term view in
mind so definitely there story Beyond
season 2 we would love to be able to
explore when season 2 The spoiler
when season 2 ends what do you think
fans are going to say uh I think it'll
be a combination of um finally and also
um yeah like I hope they're just like
come on um that's how I feel when I
watch the the finale I think there will
be a big
exhale like that just like
that no but it is like it's super
intense the last episode is very intense
so I think there really is going to be
just like a
that I'm curious how season 2 expands
the mythology of Halo cuz that's
something that a lot of people you know
they want to know that's so we don't so
much expand those mythology or I'm sorry
explore the mythology that we do yeah um
and I think that one of the great things
when you become a part of a project like
this is there's this whole menu of what
I loved as a fan that you can bring into
the story we're in a different timeline
so sometimes we arrive at those places
in a different route
um but uh yeah I mean I think that you
try to be as true as you can um and also
allow some freedom in it uh because uh
it's a different medium it's a different
uh set of given circumstances that we
come into the season with um and uh but
we were as you know and Kiki does a
really good job of keeping us um on
point in terms of you know how we
consider the lore we you're steeped in
it um and if you come to it with like
humility and respect and um at the same
time you know there's things that we all
love about the game and uh we wanted to
go to some of those places this season
there's some big events that players
will be very familiar with that we we
really get to explore and are really
core to the character Journeys right
MH